AMIT FULAY: Good afternoon, and
welcome to the session.
I hope a lot of you got a chance
to see the keynote in
the morning where we announced
this product.
And I'm really excited you could
be here as we take a
deeper dive into what
we've built.
Some housekeeping details
before we get started.
There's a session feedback link,
hash tags, and a video
recording of the session will
be on YouTube 24 hours.
In the next forty five minutes,
we've got a great agenda.
I want to start with talking
about why you should even care
about in-app payments.
Then we'll talk about what our
offering is, both in terms of
the user experience
and the API.
And we'll talk about how you can
start implementing this in
your apps as you leave
this room.
But let's start with
introductions.
Now, throughout the blogosphere,
there's always a
lot of speculation about what
happens to start-ups once
they've been acquired
by a large company.
Most of the team that built
this product started their
journey in a very similar way.
We came from an acquisition
that Goggle did in August
2010, a small start-up called
Jambool with a product Social
Gold that helped developers
monetize from within their
applications.
And we're really happy to be
here in a short span of time
having built this product
at of Google scale.
My name is Amit Fulay.
I'm a product manager on the
team, and I'll be joined by
Mikhail and Luke, engineers who
helped build this product.
The web has evolved, and so
has the way all of us make
money on it.
In its infancy, web was all
about selling physical goods
and accepting payments.
Developers built front ends to
their existing stores, took
payments, and shipped
the goods.
Then we saw a transition where
not only were they selling,
they were actually advertising
these goods on the web.
Search ads, display ads, this
was all possible because of
the introduction of really
sophisticated ad platforms
that could target and
reach users in a
very precise manner.
We saw a lot of publishers
build engaging websites,
attract eyeballs, and hence
make money through ads.
Now, over the last few years
we've seen another interesting
model come about, selling
virtual goods
from within an app.
This has been led by
the social and the
casual gaming space.
Some estimates put this to be a
$15 billion market by 2012.
So we've seen a lot of different
waves come ashore,
starting with what I call as the
shopping wave, all about
E-commerce, B2B, B2C models.
Then supplemented with an ad
wave that was all about
building audiences and making
money through advertising.
And then the third wave is what
I'd refer to as the micro
transaction wave. We've seen
increasingly users embrace a
model where they're willing to
shell out 99 cents, 79 cents,
for a song, for a tractor in a
farm, for ringtones, for apps,
for rentals.
And that's a model that really
is something new.
Let's look at another
interesting trend on the web.
We all live on increasingly
social and connected web.
At the end of 2001, there were
10 billion accounts that were
created on social networking
sites, online worlds and MMOs.
And astonishing, half of those
accounts were still active.
There's a reason a lot of us
here are willing to pay four
bucks for a cup of latte.
It's not because
of the coffee.
It's the experience of walking
up to the store, listening to
that music, seeing the barista
brew a fresh cup of coffee.
That's what we are paying for.
It's the same reason a couple
of years ago huge number of
users lined up in lines for
hours to watch the latest
movie, Avatar.
It was the 3D glasses, the IMAX
cinematic experience.
That's what stood out.
They were willing to pay a
premium in that case with
their time in order to
get that experience.
And we are beginning to see a
similar transition happen in
the online space.
It's no longer a web where you
go and click on some links.
Users want to be absorbed,
engaged in the web apps.
They decorate their profiles,
create playlists, upload
pictures, create mashups, share
with their friends,
build their farms for hours,
build chocolates in games.
It's the experience that's
driving them there.
It's no longer only
about utility.
So when we look at a confluence
of these trends, a
microtransactions model that's
being embraced by both sellers
as well as buyers, an
increasingly connected and
social web, and a user who is
inclined to pay a higher price
for experiences.
When you combine that, that's a
huge opportunity for all you
developers.
And in order to help you
capitalize on that opportunity
we introduced the Google in-app
payments for the web.
Now let's look at what this
platform has, and what this
ecosystem would look like.
But before I do that, here's
some more specifics about
we're announcing.
All U.S. developers will
be able to leave this
room and sign up.
There is the flash version of
the API that we will be
releasing in a few
weeks from now.
And our plan is to go
live this summer.
Now there's a reason we are
staging this launch starting
with the developers first.
First, we want to give you
some time to help integrate
and prep your apps.
And we want your feedback in
order to iron out anything
that's missing in this
payments platform.
So our hope is we can work
together, build some really
cool, engaging apps
that we can get in
the hands of consumers.
What does this new web app
ecosystem look like?
At the top is the application
layer.
That's where all you
developers come in.
You build engaging innovative
apps, whether it's in
productivity, publishing,
gaming, entertainment.
And you can find a distribution
channel for these
apps through a web store, like
the Chrome web store, or
through even your
own websites.
All of these can be powered by
the in-apps payments platform.
What have we built?
At the very core is the
huge Google payments
infrastructure.
This includes things like fraud
and risk management that
we don't necessarily want you
people to worry about.
That's something we have a
devoted team looking at each
and every day.
We have state of the art
compliance, whether it's in
the U.S. or internationally,
that meets all the regulations
in the way we store our credit
cards, the way we do audit,
where we log data.
And analytics that can help you
get insights into how your
users are converting.
Where do they drop off?
What time of the day are the
most purchases in your apps?
Things like that which will be
critical as you fine tune your
monetization engine.
Now, couple this payments
platform with a
large, active user base.
Any user who has bought an app
on Android market, bought an
e-book on our Google e-book
store, paid for extra storage
in Picasa, bought extra minutes
on Google Voice, all
of these users have
created accounts.
And you are bringing all
of this huge payments
infrastructure and a large user
base into your app with a
simple API.
Literally it's one call to
initiate payments and one call
to collect it.
And Mikhail will jump into what
that API looks like later
in the session so that you
know how to integrate.
But that's really what
we think is the
beauty of this platform.
One API that in a way hides
away all of the payments
complexity from you and delivers
to you a large
transacting user base
from Google.
And what your users who are
buying apps or playing with
these apps see is a very
frictionless UX.
Again, we'll see a demo
of that today.
The whole goal is simple.
Payments should get out of the
way as soon as possible.
Minimal steps, enter your
credentials, pay, and get back
to the app.
And the best part about the
user base is if they've
already paid they don't have
to enter credentials again.
It becomes single click.
Now, a lot of you have
tweeted about this.
A lot of web apps charge 30% for
payments, which we find a
little ridiculous.
It's almost become a default,
and we are not ever happy with
what the default is.
So in the morning, you saw in
the keynote, we unveiled a
flat pricing structure 5%.
Now, I want to emphasize there's
no fine print here.
This is not a pharmaceutical
ad.
This 5% means you can price your
items at 25 cents, and
because there's no fixed fee,
you're never paying an
exorbitant amount from
what you get.
You can price your items at
whatever price points you like
or your users like.
The second thing I want to
emphasize it this price point
is not only applicable on Chrome
web store, but on the
entire web.
So if you build an app and you
launch it on your own website,
you can integrate with Google
in-app and the pricing will
still be the same.
So that's what we're offering,
A flat 5% pricing structure,
simple API, and a simple UX.
Now to jump into the user
experience, I want invite on
stage Jake from PopCap one of
our early adopters, who have a
game Plants Versus Zombies some
of you might know, that
integrated with this platform.
You saw Angry Birds in the
morning, time for Plants
Versus Zombies now.
Hey, Jake.
JACOB MCMAHON: I'm going to
give you you a demo of the
in-app purchasing, but since
it's frictionless it's a
pretty quick demo, so I'll give
you a little run down of
PopCap first. Our mission
is to make fun games for
everyone, everywhere.
Our first game, Bejeweled, is
a good example of that.
We released it about 10 years
ago, and we've released that
game on over 15 different
platforms now.
And for each platform that we
release it on we customize it
for that platform so that the
users, that's the first time
they've ever played that game,
they feel like that game was
built for that platform.
We have six franchises,
major franchises.
Plants Versus Zombies is
the most recent one.
And that's actually what we're
going to do the demo with is
we've got a trial version up on
the Chrome web store, and
so what we've done is we've
added some additional
content onto it.
If you're never played Plants
Versus Zombies before, there's
two sides plants, zombies.
There's about 40 plants and
about 25 zombies, and we've
got some additional zombies
that the player can add
through microtransaction
payments.
Now, jumping into the numbers,
if you look across all of our
products we've got about 60,
more than 60 monthly active
users that are playing
our games.
If we look just at Bejeweled,
we've got over 2 billion games
played each month.
And if we look at just micro
transactions we've got over 3
million transactions
a month at an
average cost of 75 cents.
Now, we've seen this business
grow quite a bit just in the
last eight months.
It's grown more than 100%, to
more than $2.5 million a
month, and now accounts for
about 10% of our revenue.
One other number for you,
75% of our purchases are
re-orders, and that's something
that were very proud
of because that's telling us
that the users are trying our
game and they're enjoying it
and they're coming back.
And that's where we want to
focus is we want to focus on
making those great experiences
that players really enjoy.
Plants Versus Zombies, as an
example, we spent three years
making that game.
We spent a lot of time picking
the right combination of
plants and zombies and trying
to create a balanced
experience.
So as we add new zombies to that
game we want to make sure
that that supports the old game
play, as well as enhances
and evolves the game into
a new direction.
So we've got three new zombies
for this demo.
We've got a zombie in long
johns, we've got a
hairy-chested, spandex zombie,
and a naked zombie.
All right so let's switch
over to the demo.
All right so this is the trial
version that's available up on
the Chrome web store, and we
did a mock up with it.
And we added a button so that
we can purchase in it.
We just called it
the Google Mart.
And in there we've got our
three choices, spandex,
underwear, naked.
I think we should go well full
monty, go fully naked.
So the user experience
is what you'd want.
It's frictionless.
It's just two clicks to go
through the purchase sequence.
We got the API about a week
ago and mocked this up.
It was really easy to use,
quick to implement.
Maybe I didn't get it there.
There we go.
We'll see what happens.
It was quick to implement, easy
to use, which is exactly
what you would want.
Complete that purchase.
And here we go.
We will end up with our naked
zombie that we can then play
in the game, and so fantastic
experience.
So I'll hand it over
to Mikhail to
talk through the details.
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: Thank you.
Thank you, Jake.
Let me slip back over here.
Great So I''ll tell
you guys about the
API that we've built.
And as Amit has alluded to
earlier, we wanted to solve
two major problems, first one
is the buyer experience.
We want it to be very smooth so
that people don't have any
trouble making one purchase
after another, and they don't
feel like it's an obstacle for
them as they're playing a game
or using your web app.
And the second, of course, is
that we wanted to make the API
very easy for you to use so it's
not an obstacle for you
to build this in so you
can integrate quickly
and get paid sooner.
It turns out that these problems
are related and so
when you build a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you want it to model the
buyer experience.
So really to make some sort
of API you just need to
understand how the
purchase works.
And you've already seen that.
So just to review the structure,
let's say you have
a web application where
you can buy a star.
There's a buy button.
The buyer clicks on
that buy button.
It brings up the payment
screen you saw earlier.
The buyer just has to either
confirm the purchase or enter
the billing details if
they haven't already.
Payment gets processed, they
close the window, and they're
back in the application and they
have the item immediately
that they just purchased.
So to implement this API in your
application you just need
to worry about two calls.
The first call will open the
payment screen, on the second
call will accept the
notification once the payment
is complete.
So that same diagram in terms
of the API, the click
corresponds to the API call.
When a buyer clicks on a buy
button the API call is made.
And then the notification
corresponds to
the end of the purchase.
So the notification is actually
sent to you when the
purchase is complete, but before
the buyer has closed
that window.
So once the buyer has closed
that window it's guaranteed
that the purchase notification
has already been sent to you.
We think that makes it a lot
simpler for you to handle that
end of the picture flow, and
gives you fewer corner cases
to worry about.
Let's talk about, actually
before I go on I should say
one more thing.
I've been using the example of
a buy button, but that's
really not necessarily
the only way to
implement this API.
The API call is just a
JavaScript [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
call, so you can trigger
it on anything.
For example, if you have another
game and the user
completes all the levels you can
immediately bring up the
payment screen so they can buy
more levels without them
having to click anything.
Before you start writing code to
integrate this API, you'll
need to do a bit to set up.
You'll need to create a
seller account if you
don't have one already.
And then you'll need to grab a
seller ID and a secret and
you'll use those to call our
API to tell us who you are.
You'll also configure
a closed back URL.
That's the URL where we'll send
those notifications once
the payment is complete.
Let's talk about that
first call to
open the payment screen.
As a web application you
have a client side
and a server side.
The call starts on the server
side where you use your secret
key to find the parameters
of the purchase
that are being generated.
So you'll define the purchase.
You'll sign them with
your secret key.
That will produce a token which
is an encoded string.
You'll embed it in your web
application source code, and
that'll get passed into our
JavaScript library.
Here's the actual code.
This is Ruby, but it
would look pretty
similar in most languages.
So you define the purchase.
It's very simple to define.
You just tell us what's being
purchased, how much it costs,
and then you tell us
who you are when
you're calling the API.
Yet So that's that the
first code snippet.
The line at the bottom is where
you use your secret key
to sign it and generate
the token.
That JWT.encode call is
a standard library.
All you need to know is you
don't need to worry about
implementing the signature
algorithm yourself.
And Luke will tell you more
about that library we chose.
Now, you've generated that token
on the server side, and
this is the client side.
First you'll include our
JavaScript library, that's the
first code snippet.
Really you just copy and paste
that and you're done.
The second code snippet
actually
triggers the call here.
We've set up a buy button with
an on-click handler that calls
JavaScript function in our
library, and passes that item
token those generated
on the server side
into the library call.
So after you've done that, the
payment processing all happens
on our side.
The payment screen opens.
We interact with the
buyer to get
confirmation or billing details.
And once the payment is done we
process it on our servers.
We send you a server to
server notification.
It goes to that URL you've
configured earlier.
The details of that notification
will include many
of the same things you put into
the original JavaScript
library call, including the
item description of what's
being purchased, the
price, and when
that purchase happened.
We'll also include an
order ID for you.
You'll be able to use
that later to
reference this purchase.
And importantly you will
need to echo that
order ID back to us.
That way we know that you
received our notification, you
were able to decode our token,
and got the order ID out of it
so we know that the user can
reasonably expect to have the
item at that point because
you've found
out about the purchase.
And at that point we're done.
The purchase has been
delivered to you.
This is the code to implement
that notification handler.
Again, this is a rails
controller action.
This function gets called
when your server
gets a post from us.
It pulls the first line.
You see it pulls the JWT
parameter, that token, out of
the post parameters.
It decodes it using
that same standard
library I mentioned earlier.
You call from application
specific logic to give the
item to the user.
And then you acknowledge the
receipt of that post back to
us by returning a status of 200
and the order ID in the
body of the response.
If anything goes wrong, you
can just give us different
code as a response, like a 400
and then we'll understand that
you couldn't deliver the item
to the user and so we'll
cancel the order.
That way the user doesn't
pay for something
they couldn't receive.
Now, you might have noticed
that the server to server
notification comes to your
servers, but the user is
probably using the client.
So how will that item
be actually
delivered to the user?
Of course there's several
ways to go about it.
The simplest way to
do it is polling.
So your client could poll the
server side and wait for the
notification to come through.
But we can do better than that,
and so we provide an
optional mechanism for you
to use so you can pass an
optional call back into that
JavaScript library call when
you start the purchase.
These call back functions get
invoked when the purchase
either succeeds or fails.
And at that point you know
your server has also been
notified, so when the call that
is called on the client
you can check with your own
server to see if you got the
notification instead of having
pull it all the time.
Of course you do still have
to check with the server.
The JavaScript call back
itself is not enough.
The reason is any buyer with
Firebug installed or a similar
tool can go and invoke that call
back on themselves and
give themselves free stuff,
naked zombies to
their heart's content.
And so that's why you want to
check with the server to make
sure that the purchase actually
did take place.
So let's review the
whole picture.
Your servers will define a
purchase, generate a token to
represent it, and pass
it into the client.
When a buyer clicks on that buy
button the token will get
tossed into our JavaScript
library.
It will open the
payment screen.
The payment screen will talk to
our servers, complete the
purchase and you'll get a
notification first on the
server and then when the buyer
closes the payment screen the
client side as well.
And now Luke will tell you
more about how this
will work in flash.
LUKE BAYES: Hey, there.
My name 's Luke, and I've been
working with these guys since
back in the Jambool days.
I'm going to talk to you today
a little bit about the flash
integration and as well as a
few other sort of technical
details as we got into it.
So jumping right in here, this
API is actually going to be
coming soon, so we're not
shipping this today.
But in the coming--
we'll get this as
soon as we can.
We'll get this out to you.
If you want to integrate this
API with a flash application
or a flash game, the first thing
you need do is get our
library, our SWF library.
You'll download that from
our merchant area.
And you'll get that into
your SWF file, compiled
into your SWF file.
You can do that using
the line command
compiler, as you see here.
But you could also use whatever
other tools used to
build your SWF application.
So if you're using flash
authoring for example or flash
builder or flex builder or
FDT, whatever tool you're
using to build your flash
application you just embed our
library in there as a SWC file,
and you can then make
references to the code that's
compiled inside of it.
Now, the second thing you'll
need to do is get access to a
signed item token.
And again, you'll need to do
that on your server because
you don't want to compile your
secret key into your running
SWF file that's then in
people's browsers
and stuff like that.
So similar or the
JavaScript side.
Now, here we're showing an
example of how to do that
using FlashVars or object
embed using
the SWF object library.
Now this bottom snippet here is
presumably on an HTML page
that your server is rendering
in the same way that they
rendered the HTML page
as the host did
the JavaScript client.
Now, in this case, we're just
sending the same item token
there, and we're pushing
it into using a SWF
object dot add param.
Now this implementation can
work with exactly the same
back end that's driving your
HTML JavaScript client.
So you could, it's conceivable
that you could have a flash
game or flash application
that's running one
environment, an HTML JavaScript
application that's
the same application or very
similar, running for another
environment that may
not work for flash.
But your service layer could
actually be identical.
No some people aren't going to
be having just one single
button or one single item to
purchase and FlashVars may not
be appropriate.
And in that case you can
actually write an API, like
for example, maybe
a catalog API.
So you're basically loading a
collection of items off of
your server.
And all you have to do is
include a signed token for
each item that the user may
purchase in the client.
So that would work as well.
Now, the next step is we're
going to get down into the
running SWF file.
So into your application
we're writing action
script three code.
Now, this code is regular,
plain, old
action script three.
This is not you don't have to
have a flex application.
If you do that's fine.
There's no frameworks or
additional code code that need
to bring in.
But if you have other frameworks
it works fine
alongside those.
So in this case we're going to
take the buy button that you
presumable have in your app.
And like Mikhail said for
the JavaScript side.
It could be some interaction
took place.
Maybe you have a vampire that
walked up to another vampire
and when they collide
the buy screen
shows up for some reason.
In this case we've got a buy
button, and in our handler
we're going to attach to
the mouse event some
of you may see there.
where in our handler we're going
to basically go out to
the FlashVars that we saw on the
previous screen, and grab
that item token as a string.
So it's as an opaque string from
the perspective of the
running flash app.
We're going to instantiate our
library that came in in that
SWC file, and call buy item,
sending it that token.
Now this is going to load and
display the payment experience
directly within your
flash app.
So you'll be ready to go, the
user will be able to finish
their, make their purchasee.
And then when they're done
you'll get an event you can
subscribe to an optional event
like Mikhail described, but
you'll definitely get a post
back on your server.
So you can basically handle that
post back and award the
item to the user.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about JSON web tokens.
So to be clear, this
is a scheme that's
in place for signing.
And the purpose of these tokens
is for us to verify
that you were in the person, you
the seller were the person
who created this particular
item and associated this
particular price and wanted
to award it to
this particular user.
So what we're doing here is
we're verifying that the price
you've given us and who we're
going to pay when we collect
that user's money.
So we don't want to let users
in the middle, like, open up
Firebug and manipulate the
amount they're going to pay
for something.
And we certainly don't want to
let them manipulate who we're
going to pay when they
give us that money.
So the important thing here is
that we have your secret key
is what you use on your server
and you use it to sign that
information.
So you create that packet of
information and then you sign
it with your secret key.
And then you take that encoded
string as a opaque package,
and you pass it through to
our APIs and your client.
Now, the JSON web tokens is a
very recent innovation in sort
of signing technology
these days.
There are a variety of libraries
available to use
that work just great.
In getting this to work, we
actually came through a few
other implementations, one of
them being OAuth1 style
signing schemes.
Now, some you might be familiar
with OAuth One
Essentially this is an HTTP
coupled signing scheme where
you take HTTP parameters and
you sort them according to
some rules alphabetically.
Then you put some delimiters
in there and you assemble
them, and it's pretty
complicated.
And the problem is it ties your
signing scheme literally
to your web server or web
application layer.
With JSON web tokens you can
actually sign these with
native libraries in whatever
language it's written in.
You don't have to know what
object, for example, on a
rails app we have a params
object where parameters live.
And JSON so OAuth1 was
very complicated.
We got into issues at Social
Gold where we had a lot of
people having trouble
with did I get these
in the right order?
What do I do with optional
parameters?
What do I do with other
parameters that aren't even
related to this signing
scheme.
I've got some method parameter
i want to send to do an HTTP
delete or what have you.
Now, all that stuff goes
away JSON web token.
So we were really excited
when we found this.
And basically with this scheme
you just send a packet to this
method in a library and you
get back the token.
And on the other side of that
you can send the token into
this library and get back
the packet that
was originally sent.
It's really simple.
It's really easy.
And there's libraries in just
about any language.
So we're working with the
library developers.
If you do find a library in some
other language that's not
quite up to speed, just let us
know on our developer forums.
And we're working on getting
all those libraries up to
speed and keeping them up to
date with the latest version
of the JSON web token spec.
So with this spec, we also have
built a little bit of
support into our merchant center
here, where you can
take the parameters, as you're
trying to integrate you can
take the parameters that you've
got and you can put
them into this web form and hit
go and then see a token
get built in place.
You can actually paste that
code in and make it make a
call to make sure wheres
the problem as
you're trying to debug.
This'll take-- is my signing
code the problem, or is my
application code the problem?
Is the library the problem,
like, what's happening?
This let you narrow that problem
set down and see my
signing code is actually
generating a different
signature with these inputs,
there must be a problem in my
signing code, perhaps in
the library, perhaps in
how I'm using it.
And this is a great tool that I
think will be really helpful
for a lot of people.
Now some of you may have noticed
that as we look at
those diagrams that Mikahil
had, we had this process
beginning in a client, in
a browser of some kind
somewhere, and then
our servers are
calling your servers.
Now there's a little bit of an
issue there in that you're
probably wondering how do I know
which user was in that
browser in order to associate
this purchase and give them
the right thing?
Well, the way we're encouraging
you to do that is
through this field called seller
data, which is just a
field on the hash that you send
to the library, to the
signing library.
Put this in your
JSON web token.
It's an opaque string from
our perspective.
We don't care what's in there.
You can put whatever you want
in there, and you can use it
to associate a purchase with
a user in your context.
So we're not going to leak user
data to you, and we're
prefer it if you didn't
leak user data to us.
And it's important that
you encrypt that date.
Now, as I said before,
JSON web tokens
is a signing scheme.
It's not an encryption scheme.
So we're relying on HTTPS for
encryption, but we want to
make sure that you keep your
user information secure
according to the terms of your
relationship with your users.
And that means secure
from us as well.
So you should encrypt
that information.
If you put personally
identifying information there
you should encrypt it as you
send it in, and you should
decrypt it when you
get it out.
And we're going to
pass it through.
So we're going to send you back
a JSON web token that's
very similar, but not the same
as the one that you sent that.
And when we send that back we'll
include whatever you
gave us an that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
data field.
And that will allow you to do
things like hey, I just got a
post back that said someone
bought something.
Here's who bought it,
user ID 12345.
But you can also do interesting
things in addition
to that, like, oh, actually
this session was initiated
from this refer from one of my
partners and I want to award
them some percentage of that fee
since I made so much money
only giving Google 5%, right?
So now then basically you
can have these sales.
You can have discounts.
You can have refers.
You can put whatever
you want in there.
And you can structure that
information however you want
as long as it encodes
and decodes to JSON.
So if you want to but some other
binary blob in there and
just encode it as a string,
that's fine.
Now, I'm going to wrap up with
that, and bring Amit up here
to finish this thing up.
Thank you.
AMIT FULAY: Thanks, Luke
and Mikhail and Jake.
Hopefully that gives you a sense
of what the experience
is, what the API
set looks like.
Just to quickly recap simplicity
has been a core
focus in all aspects of the
product that we've built, API,
user experience, as
well as pricing.
You can get started today.
There's a short URL for
you to remember.
That's the home page for
in-app payments.
If you already have an account
you can sign in or you can
create a new account.
API is available for
you to play with.
The documentation
is available.
We have a Google group that we
will be actively monitoring,
including the engineering
and the product team.
So if you have questions, you
have feedback, please
do send it to us.
Once again, the hope is we can
fill the gaps in anything that
you think is missing, give you
some lead time to integrate
all of your apps with this
new payments platform.
And come summer let delight
users and make some money.
Thank you
If you have questions, please
go up to the mike.
Mikhail, Luke you want
to come here.
We can answer any questions
you have. Please?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a couple of places
actually, and just looking at
it, can you hear me?
AMIT FULAY: Yes, if you
come a little closer.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
couple of questions.
I can see in the URL that
if somehow a brother to
Google check out.
Is that also why the postback
for the yes or no pretty much
when I send the payment yes or
no it's still asynchronous?
Why can't I just get that reply
right there instead of
me trying to identify the just
like any kind of credit card
processing, pretty much like
in a gateway process.
Is that is that also
why that is?
AMIT FULAY: Okay, so first let
me summarize the questions.
There's two parts to
your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah Yes, exactly.
AMIT FULAY: The first part is,
is it still check out UC check
out in the URL somewhere,
and the second was is it
asynchronous or not?
AUDIENCE: Yes because in that
demo the server gets a post
which pretty much says whether
or not the transaction was
good or not, instead
of me getting it at
the point of purchase.
So there's this flow that's
synchronous, and then there's
the flow that's asynchronous
that's happening in the
background that I have to
somehow poll before I give
access to something.
If I had that synchronously
then it's right there.
It happens right there.
AMIT FULAY: That's a great
question, so let me answer the
first part and I'll let Mikhail
answer the second part.
As far as check out is
concerned, so I showed in the
diagram the whole Google
payments infrastructure.
Check out is also built
on top of that.
Check out was a product that was
tailored towards physical
goods, shipping goods,
that e-commerce wave
that I talked about.
And we're taking that payments
kind of platform and building
and innovating on top that.
So you're seeing in-app payments
being the first kind
of incarnation.
Check out was the older one for
the physical goods, and
you'll see some more offerings
coming from us in the future.
As far as the synchronous
transactions, I'll let Mikhail
answer that.
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: Yes, so
regarding the synchronous
transactions, I think we
actually made it as close to
synchronous as possible in
JavaScript So when you open
the payment screen you don't
want that buy item call you
first make to be synchronous
because you don't want it to
block the whole thread.
And so that's why we had to make
the JavaScript call backs
on the other side be call backs
instead of just the
return of that call.
The reason it's very close to
synchronous is because that
server post back is guaranteed
to finish before the
JavaScript call backs
are invoked.
So you actually don't have
to do the polling.
You can just check at the
time of the call back.
AMIT FULAY: Yes please
go ahead.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: So this is cool, but
what if I mean, I like how
fast it goes, but what if my
users don't want quite that
experience?
You know the problem with kids
using daddy's credit card for
too fast of an in-app
purchase.
Or the reverse of that, what if
there's a user time out, if
the user gets up and leaves and
comes back and completes
his transaction half
an hour later.
How do those kind of cases--
AMIT FULAY: It's a
great question.
So let me to repeat for
the recording here.
It sometimes goes too fast. What
happens to users who are
probably not trained, do they
end up making purchases when
they don't even realize it?
I think that's the question,
and that's a fair point.
We did think about this, and if
you there is today in the
payments experience an
acknowledgement, a complete.
The user has to explicitly agree
to buy an item before
the purchase completes.
We had talked about coming up
with a model that's only
single click.
So you basically click on
an item and you get it.
You don't even have
to acknowledge if
you trust that developer.
So there is kind of a fine
balance, and this is something
I think will have to
evolve the model
as we get more feedback.
But we have kept this
experience.
It is kind of two step simply to
kind of avoid that problem.
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: And just to
add a little bit to that, I
think that's one of the things
we're refining during this
trial period where you guys are
integrating and asking us
these questions.
So that was an issue
that came up.
We these steps that Amit
described to address them, and
we are thinking about
doing more things.
LUKE BAYES: And to add to that,
I think there's the
expire field as well, so
developer to developer.
Control that to some extent?
How long their signatures
are valid, for example?
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: Yes so you can
the developers have some
control over how long those
purchase tokens are valid.
So they're valid indefinitely.
AUDIENCE: Yes, okay, so
do you have any--
since you didn't talk about it,
I'm going to assume that
there's no support for a
subscription model then?
AMIT FULAY: So the question
is is there support for
subscription model?
We don't have in the product
we are launching today.
That's something that we
are going to build
in the coming months.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
And do you also have APIs and
such so that since you're
handling the payment and such,
do you have APIs avaliable so
that we could query what is the
transaction history of a
given user so that we don't have
to keep any logging on
our end as far as what
happened and who paid
what and all that?
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: Not
at this time.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I have a
question about the revelation
with Android purchase and what
if we have the same code base
for Chrome app and in JavaScript
and a Android app
in a package like phone
gap or something?
Can we use that or are we
supposed to use two different
payment system?
AMIT FULAY: Yes, so the question
is how does it relate
to Android app, if I were
to paraphrase that.
Actually I see some of the folks
leaving so I'm going to
interrupt the answer one minute,
and we do have some
special session t-shirts that
you should collect on your way
out if you are leaving.
But coming back to the question,
Android app, which
is the mobile app.
So there's a couple of kind of
clarifications I'll make,
which is we're using the same
underlying payments
infrastructure.
And when I talked about that
account, the user base that
has transacted on any of these
properties that kind of comes
with along.
So the user that's an Android
app that created an account
there, that's applicable here.
They have single signing.
So as far as the payments
underlying
infrastructure that is shared.
Now, mobile and a pure
web, they are
inherently different models.
You see that difference between
Chrome web store and
mobile specific marketplaces.
And so the pricing structure
will be what
applies to either case.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: This is a question to
add on to the first person.
So if of call back to the server
is synchronous right So
what happens if the server
end we cannot handle it.
For example like our game server
may be overloaded.
So you send this to us, like
we cannot deliver the good
because like that there's some
issue with the system.
Is the transaction comes through
that completed or is
the transaction--
or do we have to do something
as to tell is that we're
having some Issues
AMIT FULAY: Yes, please.
Could you please repeat
the question?
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: The question
was what happens if you
couldn't acknowledge the post
back or if you return an error
instead of a success on that
post bask acknowledgement.
LUKE BAYES: And/or a time out.
MIKHAIL SEREGINE:
Or a time out.
And the answer is that at that
point the buyer is still
looking at the payment screen
and we show them that we could
not deliver the item and that
that order will be cancelled.
AUDIENCE: Can I do something
like a return to using the
transaction is completed on my
end but it's going to later to
deliver to the user?
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: No, we want
the user experience to be
either successful
or a failure.
So that if they want to get the
purchase later they just
have to go again and
try it again.
AUDIENCE: Okay, so what would
you suggest in the case of
like a massive sale,
like let's say the
game is really popular.
They're doing a flash sale for
like five minute or an hour?
LUKE BAYES: You should host
your app on app engine.
[LAUGHTER]
MIKHAIL SEREGINE: So in order,
if the users can't get the
thing they're buying,
then that's a
part of the same problem.
Is if your app is overloaded
they might not even be able to
get to the purchase screen.
So if that part of app works
then the postback handling
should also work.
LUKE BAYES: And the truth is
this is an in-app experience.
So this is a user who was in
your app, let's use a game as
an example.
So they're in the and they'e
just they're getting
frustrated in Angry Birds
and they can't.
They want that eagle and they
want to do it, and they click
buy, and then you want to tell
them no, you can't have it for
like a day or two.
So in this case because we're
in-app it's not like something
you're buying that might ship
tomorrow from Amazon It's
something they want right now.
They went immediate
gratification.
So we're thinking of it from
the user's perspective.
They either want it or
they don't want to
be charged for it.
And this is something we
learned at Jambool,
at Social Gold was--
AUDIENCE: But I'm not
talking about day.
I'm talking about like
let's say five minute
or something shorter.
It's just not like 30 seconds.
LUKE BAYES: We should probably
talk about that.
So that's actually--
AUDIENCE: Yes, okay Thank you.
I don't want to talk.
AMIT FULAY: The gentleman
in the back?
AUDIENCE: So what about support,
like if there's a to
user has any need dispute,
anything that does the poll
goes to direct, goes to Google
first or go to like the app
seller first?
AMIT FULAY: So the question
is the Google group, who's
supporting that.
AUDIENCE: No like the
user support.
AMIT FULAY: Oh the
AUDIENCE: Support
for the user.
AMIT FULAY: I see.
So as far as the payments
dispute what happened to my
credit card?
It didn't go through.
that is all using the existing
support mechanisms that we
have with Google payments.
That's is also with check out,
so we will have the same
support team, sensible same
support forums. that you'll
get for the end user.
So you'll get that.
LUKE BAYES: But we're
growing that.
AMIT FULAY: Yes, and we're
staffing it as we get more
developers.
So does that answer
your Question
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And a second question is
how to handle refund?
AMIT FULAY: How do you
handle refunds?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMIT FULAY: So we are actually
working through the whole
refund chargeback policy.
If you subscribe to the
groups we'll do
an update very shortly.
AUDIENCE: Okay, and one more
question is that so you say
that the flash API is not yet
available but I think Plants
Versus Zombies is a flash game
and how do they integrate?
AMIT FULAY: So the question is
flash API is not available,
Plants Versus Zombies
is a flash game.
So Jake, I can answer
on his behalf.
I think they are using PopCap
has moved to using am HTML
based payments flow.
So They are using the HTML
version, JavaScript
version of the API.
LUKE BAYES: And I can answer
that a little bit, too.
Many flash games use a window
mode setting when they embed
their script that draws directly
to the screen.
And some flash games don't,
some flash games do.
Depending how that setting is
done, you may or may not be
able to overlay an iframe
above a flash--
a running flash application.
And so our flash API is
specifically and especially
for those games or applications
that cannot
overlay an iframe and want to
have the application, all the
application handling
done directly in
action script three.
But you can, if you're in the
case where you can overlay,
you can pretty easily use
external interface or some
other means to talk to
JavaScript on the page and
load iframe above your app and
let it close and get the call
backs that way.
AMIT FULAY: It should
be on now.
Try.
LUKE BAYES: Try now.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Yes.
So basically they are using as
standard interface code to
invoke the JavaScript,
yes, is how they--
LUKE BAYES: I believe so.
Is it?
I assume that's true.
Yes, I'm getting
nods over here.
That's sounds right.
for this demo, yes.
AMIT FULAY: And the PopCap, a
couple of folks from PopCap
are also here so you can, if
you have more follow-up
questions, feel free
to ask them.
AUDIENCE: All right. thank you
LUKE BAYES: Thank you.
AMIT FULAY: We'll take a
question in the back.
AUDIENCE: How do I get it?
AMIT FULAY: How do I get what?
AUDIENCE: How do I
sign up to be a--
AMIT FULAY: Ah, so there's
a URL here to sign up.
And probably this is the one on
the top that you're going
to remember.
So go to goo.gl/5percentfees
it will take you
to the sign up page.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And is there a minimum browser
level for this?
I mean does this support like
IOS three or Android 2.0 or
IE7 or that kind of stuff?
AMIT FULAY: So the
question is, is
there a minimum browser?
So we are supporting all
standard browsers.
It's in our documentation.
I believe it's IE7 and above,
FireFox 3.0 Android browser,
Safari, so we'll support
all standard browsers.
LUKE BAYES: I think we're
tailoring the experience right
now for the desktop,
to clarify that.
AMIT FULAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to ask a
follow-up question about the
Android thing?
So I understood Android store
has a different cut, and there
whole lots of reasons
for that.
But if I do an Android app and I
use your API to do an in-app
purchase, are you going
to disable that?
Are you going to take a
different cut because it's an
Android app?
How's that going to work?
AMIT FULAY: So the question is
there are different models of
Android on the web.
What happens if you build an
Android app and use our API?
You cannot use this API for
native Android apps.
Anything that's a web app and
if you're on the phone and
you're using the web and you're
getting to your app
through the web, it's not
a native app, then you
can use this API.
So there's a distinction between
native and web apps.
This platform is for
wherever web apps.
AUDIENCE: Okay, thanks.
AMIT FULAY: Yes,
next question?
AUDIENCE: When will you make
this available for
international developers?
AMIT FULAY: Yes that's a great
question, when will you make
it available for international
developers?
I mentioned we're going
to go live in summer.
At that point we'll support
all our international
developers.
So whatever Google payments
supports, I think I believe
it's 21 countries, several
countries, so you can have 21
different locations where
developers can sign up and
have local currencies
and stuff like that.
So the summer launch will have
the international component.
Yes please go.
AUDIENCE: Yes, obviously kind
of excited about this.
You said that this was based on
the payments platform, so
can we leverage our existing
checkout, the notifications,
the signing, and all that?
Or is this totally different?
AMIT FULAY: So question is
can you leverage the
notifications?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Because you said that this was
somehow on top of that whole
payments infrastructure, which
is where checkout is also
based out of.
Can we leverage existing
knowledge already about the
API for checkout, for example,
like the notification?
There's some similarity in there
and then the signing and
all that, so just wondering?
LUKE BAYES: It will
be similar, but
it's not the same.
So you will have to go do
this in-app integration.
AMIT FULAY: I mean one other
focus has been that you don't
have to worry about a lot of
concepts when you integrate.
So in the check out classical
physical goods
model you have carts.
You have shipping.
Taxes, You have to worry
about a lot of things.
And the API actually hides
all of that complexity.
It's basically price, currency
and description, and that's
all you need to worry about.
So our hope is you don't
have to use some of
the different models.
That's good.
Gentleman in the back and then
I'll take your question.
AUDIENCE: Which group of
international developers are
going to get access to this?
Is it going to be the ones that
can sell on Android or
the ones that can sell
any Google checkout.
Countries like Canada can't
do Google checkout yet.
AMIT FULAY: So the question
is regarding Canada.
I don't have an accurate answer
for you right now.
But we will follow-up in
our groups postings
so please do subscribe.
And we'll actually publish a
detailed an international
rollout plan.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I have a vertical portal,
okay, website.
So would it be possible to
implement the Google payments
in that website?
And in that case will it compete
with Google, PayPal,
and all of the other
types of checkout
that are in the market?
AMIT FULAY: So I'll repeat
your question.
You have a vertical website
where you want to integrate
payments, and will this
platform work?
Absolutely.
As I said, this is not only
Chrome web store, for any web
app on the web.
So you can integrate
it no matter where
your application resides.
I'm not sure about the second
part of your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, the second part
is when you have the check out
and if you can integrate this,
the Google app, and then you
also have, for example, the
PayPal type payment, and then
the user will have to choose
one of them to check out.
So basically they are competing
and is the one who
will decide will be the user
either to take the Google one
or the PayPal one?
AMIT FULAY: Yes, absolutely.
So the question is if you have
competing payment options, and
I think that's fair.
There's nothing that precludes
you from doing that.
You can have PayPal,
Amazon, Google.
That's kind of a practice.
A lot of websites accept
payments from different
things, and it's up
to your users what
they want to choose.
So you can absolutely do that.
LUKE BAYES: There is one
more thing to clarify.
This is, and I don't think
it was made clear.
This is for virtual
and digital goods.
So if you have a website that
sells physical products to
people that you mail to them,
then this is not appropriate
API for you.
So we certainly could be nest to
a PayPal button for virtual
digital goods in an environment
like that.
AUDIENCE: Will it develop
into that in the future?
LUKE BAYES: We'll see how
the platform evolves.
AUDIENCE: So i have a lot of
questions here, the first one
is what kind of user
data we have?
Like, can we get even
like user name
or address, or anything?
And the second one is like what
kind of user analytics
you provide if we
use this API?
Thanks.
AMIT FULAY: So I'll repeat
the question.
What kind of user data we
have so could you--
AUDIENCE: If user purchase any
virtual good, right, I assume
my system knows like what's the
first name and the last
name and address and everything,
all right?
So what kind of user data we
as like the vendor or the
developer gets?
AMIT FULAY: Yes.
So the question is what of
user data that Google
collection will be shared
with developers?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
AMIT FULAY: So that the data,
because it's very sensitive,
so it's an NPAI.
It's credentials, payments
credentials, address, name, we
do not share this data--
AUDIENCE: Okay.
AMIT FULAY: with
any developer.
AUDIENCE: Okay so then what
kind of like user
analytics do we have?
Like do you know, like, I
don't know, maybe to age
between, like, 25 to 35 purchase
this item within the
first month or something like
that, concerning analytics.
AMIT FULAY: You're not looking
for a analytics with the
demographic data.
We don't have that today.
Our analytics is basically
across the user base.
It's anonymized so we basically
tell you how they
are converting.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Thanks.
LUKE BAYES: And again, we have
our forums are open so we're
hoping that questions, like
that, like you guys can help
guide the product as we work
this summer over it.
AMIT FULAY: Thank you for
your time and patience.
I'm being asked to leave
and vacate the stage.
Thanks.
Thanks for joining us.